la audiencia especial que fue convocada
por la corte internacional de justicia
para evaluar el alegato presentado por
ucrania por genocidio en contra de rusia
terminó al mediodía de este lunes 7 de
marzo en el desarrollo de la sesión no
participaron ni representantes ni
delegados del gobierno de rusia y se
conocía las últimas horas que el sábado
5 de marzo el gobierno de vladímir putin
entregó una carta a través de la cual
confirmó que su país no participaría en
esta jornada ante la corte en la cual
fueron escuchados los argumentos
presentados por parte de ucrania en los
cuales se pide el cese de las
operaciones militares en su territorio
por parte de rusia lo que prosigue ahora
será un proceso de deliberación que ya
fue iniciado por la corte internacional
de justicia todavía no se conoce en qué
fecha exacta será dado a conocer el
veredicto pero lo que busca a ucrania
con esta audiencia y con la presentación
de su alegato es que rusia detenga los
bombardeos en su país en virtud de la
convención que busca sancionar y
prevenir el genocidio